so my question is does it really matter
what does would you view the universe
differently if we knew it was simulated
could we do the math differently ooh I
like that
to make this efficient we'll pick one
person to answer so how about mats
because you have your book is title
what's the title of your book our
mathematical universe yes so he's the
guy to answer this question okay if you
knew would your math be different well
I'll take your questions I mean if I
knew would that make me super depressed
or super excited it would have change
the way I feel about everyday life my
answer is absolutely not I feel that
when we look at these rather sterile
equations or the computer code or
whatever it is it's running this you
know there's no meaning or purpose built
into that we should look to our universe
creating the meaning for us it's we who
give me any to our universe
so the way we feel about things and the
meaning we create is the same regardless
of whether we're simulated or not and I
think this is very much the point that
David was making earlier also we
shouldn't this thing is just because
they're simulated the math is a little
bit different if we're simulated on the
other hand because there's also the math
of the simulating universe where as a
math of our universe embedded in a
bigger one which raises some exciting
prospects like hey maybe we could get
out and explore that one so that'll be
cool well like so so you're saying can
you embed a complete system of
mathematics within a higher system of
mathematics yeah maybe the embedding
universe is a vastly higher level of
complexity than ours in order to have
the computational power for example to
simulate ours hey maybe they'll let us
out one day we're just computers in
their world so I'll give us input
devices so you feel like you're in
prison
no it's just like you know it's like
Earth is cool but the galaxy is even
cooler it's like always interests me
that if you miss a basketball game and
you know it already happened it's less
interesting to you to watch even though
you know it happened already and because
it's not happening in real time and you
might not even know the result but I
think there is a sense of it
psychologically the idea that it is
proof
programmed would be disturbing at least
to me you know my analogy to that is if
you go to the Smithsonian Air and Space
Museum in Washington and you see the
Apollo 11 command module that went to
the moon and came back and there it is
if you made an exact replica of that and
put it on display anywhere else and say
you cannot really tell the difference
except microscopically but it's a fake
didn't make it means if it's different
to you even though you can't tell the
difference the knowledge that is real
seems to matter to us then if it's a
simulation or a model in that case so I
have to agree I reluctantly agree well I
don't want to agree but I have to agree
I disagree for one reason to read I
don't do science to make me feel
something I do science because I think
it's an investment in the long-term
survival of our species our science
underlies our technology if our
environment changes we will use that
technology to survive
well that's true whether we're
simulations or not that's why I do
science
are you also running for president by
the way Jim Gates is on the President's
Commission a committee of Advisors of
Science and Technology PCAST and you've
been there for almost the entire
administration so keep up the good
advice forgive
[Applause]